who is Nick Cannon as a dad segwaying
off of that and you're talking about
energy to the kids I mean right now Nick
Cannon is a dad the numbers are growing
a whole bunch of [ __ ] I mean I
mean you just had you just had a new
baby yeah right yeah uh crazy our kids
are so similar and amazing
um I get to that space man of there's a
level of responsibility total total
number I don't know man you're gonna put
me on the spot I'm saying it's like
Spades I got eight in the possible nine
[Laughter]
children damn it I like that you like
Pro Korean procreating you want you want
to the name the Canon name is going to
live on forever but that but coming from
a space of like man I'm really trying to
build and and establish as much as I
possibly can because I feel like as a
provider so I mean right now as we sit
here you know being even having six kids
or it it gives me the ability to say man
I can affect
so much and even you know
me and Mariah's twins are like just
seeing what that entity building now
they're going to be they pre-teens and
well I'm like damn I didn't know that
that was going to turn into that and
then watch a legacy come out of that and
and my youngest having you know a new
baby girl and watching
her have
it's a different world so that's like
that responsibility to be able to say
not only did I put this energy into this
space but now I have to be man enough to
stand firm in who I am so that I could
be an example to them yes and that's and
that's vulnerability that's that's
emotions that's like so I'll I'll never
try to get it right I never try to be
that perfect example you know what I
mean like it's it's as cliche as the
song to say yeah I ain't trying to be a
role model because a role is something
you play you know I mean we're just out
here trying to be authentic we're trying
to be real models we're trying not even
not models because a role is something
that you play
I'd love to talk to you because I listen
I find myself just honestly listening
okay so on some on some real [ __ ] let's
talk this for a second because this is
what I struggle with and I see you deal
with it very well because naturally I'm
an introvert I don't you you you fall
back the bigger room gets you Fade to
the back yeah and you don't you don't
like you effortlessly walk into a room
and control the energy I don't like
controlling the energy in the room why
you it's
I don't know I don't want that
responsibility but I don't think it's
more of a responsibility I think that
you know rather observe I'm an introvert
I'm a natural introvert but even into
that question because you do it so
effortlessly you move you move like a
king you move you walking oh [ __ ] you're
like I'd rather be a little bit more
silent and I think that's an insecurity
of mine because
I have this I struggle with
as much as I don't want to be accepted
as much as I want to be different from
everybody I think coming up the way we
came up I have this issue with
I call it just it's real syndrome
I can't call it that that's what
that's what we call it that
has to have that Discovery okay so I'll
say just like this in this real con
we're sitting up here's cameras and yeah
this is this man this is hopefully like
I said it'd be documented like man those
two friends two brothers sitting up
there having great conversation but
to the cat that's on the Block to the
cat that doesn't get to experience these
rooms that you control when you walk in
are we really connecting are we actually
being our authentic self right now you
are
to hear you talk I love talking to you
because flawed unflawed you're you're
you and you know the way you talk the
way you speak
people this here man
you're so comfortable with being
uncomfortable you're so you're so okay
with saying yo therapy I'm not getting
it right I don't know this or trying to
figure this out why do people care I
don't know man like it's you're asking
yourself these questions you're trying
to figure this stuff out you're a work
in progress as am I as am I a forever
work in progress and here's the thing
we're never going to get it right
it's never going to be perfect in fact
we're never going to walk on a straight
line we're still going to trip we're
still going to fall but if we can
continue to be better than we were the
day before the week before then we're
doing our job this right here to me this
is this is doing our job this is a dope
ass conversation and it was real people
don't get to hear us talk like this no
it's real [ __ ] and that's what this is
about how much I owe you you don't owe
me anything but you know the therapist
where they say [ __ ] like that they just
charge me out they charge no no charge
man Nick I appreciate you coming on man
amazing conversation great dialogue
[Music]